bonjour à tous et en effet on vient de
parler de la pêche on va parler avec
vous marqueno de tout ce que l'on peut
trouver dans nos assiettes puisque vous
êtes le ministre de l'Agriculture et de
la souveraineté alimentaire comme le
disait Damien il y a un an jour pour
jour le salon de l'agriculture qui va
ouvrir ses portes demain coincées avec
le lancement de la guerre en Ukraine un
triste anniversaire et d'ailleurs ce
salon avait été perturbé Emmanuel Macron
avait coursé sa visite remplacé par le
Premier ministre un an après qu'est-ce
qu'on peut dire de l'impact de cette
guerre aussi sur le monde agricole en
France et dans le monde d'avoir l'impact
sur les consciences sans doute
c'est-à-dire qu'on s'est rendu compte de
ce qu'on croyait être des éléments
stables c'est à dire que sur le
continent européen au fond vivons plutôt
dans un espace de paix on a basculé dans
quelque chose qui était une forme
d'inconnu ou d'un pensée ou d'impensable
les spécifiquement dans le monde sur le
sujet agricole on a découvert aussi que
d'abord
la souveraineté n'était pas un acquis et
qu'il suffisait qu'on bloque des ports
pour que le flux de céréales ne puisse
pas sortir et deux on a découvert à quel
point avait construit une stratégie
offensive autour de deux axes l'énergie
et l'alimentation et qu'il avait fait de
l'alimentation une arme une arme de
pression sur la Russie notamment de
résister aux sanctions
et ça permet aussi à la Russie d'essayer
de limiter les sanctions puisque il y a
un certain nombre de pays qui peuvent
dépendre de la Russie pour se nourrir et
qui donc ne peuvent pas avoir la même
attitude qu'un pays qui souverain
vis-à-vis de son alimentation et donc ça
a remis au coeur finalement de
l'actualité il y avait longtemps qu'on
l'avait oublié sans doute
nous non mais il y a un certain nombre
de gens l'avaient oublié que la
souveraineté alimentaire s'était un
élément stratégique et c'était un
élément géopolitique et ça a changé
aussi des choses pour les agriculteurs
français ça a changé pour les
agriculteurs français une tension
inflationniste sur un certain nombre de
choses des prix qui ont augmenté sur
d'autres je pense en particulier au
céréales donc ça a eu des effets c'est
eu des effets comme pour tous les
Français mais pour le secteur agricole
de mouvement sur les marchés
de dérèglement des marchés qui ont été
très puissants le salon de l'agriculture
il ouvre donc ses portes France
Télévisions et partenaires à partir de
demain
on voit la fameuse égérie l'égérie au
Mali 50 vaches de salaire à laquelle
Emmanuel Macron viendra rendre visite
comme c'est la tradition demain on parle
d'une profession aussi qui est en plein
renouvellement ou plutôt qu'il y a des
difficultés à se renouveler on a calculé
je crois que 150000 agriculteurs vont
prendre leur retraite d'ici 10 ans
est-ce qu'il est assez de jeunes
générations c'est tout le défi
d'ailleurs du travail que nous venons
pour aboutir à un texte de loi qui
permettra d'essayer de cadrer et de
faire en sorte qu'on donne envie à des
jeunes donner envie à des jeunes c'est
quoi c'est d'essayer de gérer la
question de la rémunération c'est ce
qu'on a fait au travers des gallimes
c'est d'essayer de donner des
perspectives on va sans doute en parler
en termes de dérèglement climatique
c'est-à-dire de dire dans le modèle qui
est en train de changer en terme
climatique qu'est-ce qu'on doit changer
pour faire en sorte qu'un jeune ne se
trouve pas en situation d'impasse
technique on passe économique c'est
aussi l'image du métier et c'est au
cinéma ce que nous portons nous sur le
métier
plus nous dirons à quel point cette
profession a du sens et on en a besoin à
la fois pour nous nourrir fonction
première et deux pour un certain nombre
d'enjeux environnementaux climatiques et
autres plus on en vient on donnera envie
à des jeunes donc c'est plusieurs sujets
qu'il faut essayer de donner envie à des
jeunes mais le mal-être des agriculteurs
et c'est une réalité chaque année il y a
des centaines de suicides parmi les
paysans les agriculteurs une
sur-représentation par rapport au reste
de la population vous allez pouvoir
publique se sont penchés plusieurs fois
sur cette question il y avait eu
notamment un rapport du Sénat est-ce que
vous allez annoncer de nouvelles mesures
est-ce que vous allez prendre de
nouvelles on continue à déployer on
continue à déployer un projet qui était
celui de département par département
d'avoir une cellule qui traite de ces
questions là le grand sujet autour du
suicide ou du mal-être en agriculture
c'est que la parole se libère au fond
que les excusez-moi
dans le monde agricole qui fait qu'on ne
dit rien jusqu'au moment où on bascule
dans l'impensable d'une certaine façon
ou dans le pire c'est à dire l'acte
ultime d'un suicide et donc ce qu'il
faut c'est qu'on arrive que tous les
maillons de la chaîne soit en vigilance
c'est autant la responsabilité des
services de l'état des champs
d'agriculture de la mutualité sociale
agricole des responsables syndicaux et
donc on a dans chaque préfecture on
continue à le déployer une cellule qui
veille et qui dit cette agriculteur il a
eu un cas de grippe aviaire il a une
difficulté financière comment on
l'accompagne pour qu'il puisse exprimer
sa difficulté avec les mots qu'il a
envie de choisir avec les mots qu'on
doit trouver pour éviter qu'après ils
s'enferme et il bascule dans quelque
chose d'autre bah fait nous vous parliez
du dérèglement climatique il y a
quelques instants l'actualité du moment
c'est la sécheresse plus de 30 jours
sans pluie en hiver ça ne s'était jamais
vu quel est l'état des lieux précis
au moment où nous nous parlons est-ce
qu'il y a un déficit de nappes
phréatiques que l'on n'a pas connu à
cette période
quels sont les chiffres qui vous
remontent on a un déficit qui est
préoccupant plus de 60% des nappes ou
des réserves qui sont qui sont sous
capacités en sous et après une
répartition
équivalente quasiment entre celles qui
sont à l'étage normal et celles qui sont
plutôt est-ce que la situation la
qualifieriez quoi de catastrophique
non parce que elle est inquiétante et
donc ça nécessite c'est c'est le sens de
ce qu'il y a évoquer Christophe BECHU
mon collègue de l'environnement on va
travailler sur une anticipation parce
que on a des données qui sont des
données inquiétantes donc on a besoin
d'anticiper il y a un certain nombre de
départements 4 de tête qui sont en train
de prendre des mesures sur qui les
arrosages qui pouvaient être favorables
à ce qu'il y ait davantage de
restrictions il faut la question c'est
que de faire en sorte qu'au cas par cas
contiennent ces sujets alors après les
réserves d'eau l'état inquiétant c'est
si nous avions en plus un été très sec
comme nous avons eu l'an dernier c'est
réserves d'eau ne pourraient pas être
mobilisé on peut aussi avoir un été ou
un printemps ou une suite de printemps
qui soit plus humide sauf que le stock
on reconstitue normalement l'hiver ne
s'est pas reconstitué ou un parfaitement
reconstitué et donc c'est ça qui est un
objet de préoccupation Météo France
maintenant
un moyen terme dans ce contexte est-ce
que vous marquéno ministre de
l'Agriculture vous êtes favorable à ce
qu'on voit maintenant sur les écrans
c'est retenu d'eau c'est méga bassine
qui suscite la controverse les
agriculteurs ils sont favorables les
écologistes les dénoncent il y avait eu
on s'en souvient dans les Deux Sèvres il
y a quelques mois de des affrontements à
ce sujet Quel est vous votre position à
ma position c'est qu'on a besoin
d'ouvrage de ce type là pourquoi pour
faire en sorte que dans la période où il
y a de l'eau
pour un motif simple elle prend l'eau
pourquoi pour nous nourrir donc l'eau
que prennent les agriculteurs c'est pas
de l'eau pour eux c'est de l'eau pour
nous
responsabilité protégée et les
développer c'est ce que vous il faut les
développer dès lors que on voit bien que
les ça permet de respecter des
équilibres
hydrographiques si je peux dire
déséquilibre en termes de cycle de l'eau
et il faut aussi en même temps se mettre
sur la trace et la volonté qu'on a de
faire évoluer les pratiques mais c'est
sur les deux pieds qu'on va avancer il y
a des secteurs si on n'a pas de réserve
en contenu de la rétinie du cycle des
pluies il y aura plus d'agriculture donc
il faut c'est comme ça qu'il faut se
poser les autres solutions c'est
l'utilisation des eaux usées c'est un
débat qui est en train de monter ce que
vous souhaitez que la station je peux
vous annoncer ce matin on est en train
de on a envoyé au Conseil d'État où ça
part au Conseil d'État un texte qui vise
à la réutilisation des eaux
les eaux grises les eaux usées pourquoi
parce que nous sommes à 1,8%
d'utilisation de ces eaux en France
quand on Italie on est à 15 ou 17 %.
donc à 10 fois plus et donc c'est aussi
vertueux de se dire toute goutte pour
tout le monde citoyen que nous sommes
agriculteurs et les précieuses et donc
si on peut la recycler si on peut la
réutiliser dans une forme de
d'économie circulaire de l'eau on le
fait donc on a un décret en Conseil
d'État qui s'agitation va changer la
législation va changer pour assouplir et
clarifier un certain nombre de choses
c'était des freins on n'a pas aucune
raison aucune raison objective qu'on
fasse moins bien que les Italiens que
les Espagnols que les Allemands sur ces
sujets là et donc cette réutilisation
d'eau c'est aussi une réponse la réserve
d'eau c'est une réponse les économies
qu'on peut constituer dans l'agriculture
c'est une réponse il y a aussi des
ouvrages qui existent je pense au Cano
et qui sont aujourd'hui en vasés et
qu'on peut dans le pour lesquels on peut
libérer de l'eau et ça permettra aussi
de trouver des masses d'eau pour pour
l'irrigation vous parliez d'autres pays
européens ils n'ont pas aussi la même
législation tout le monde n'a pas la
même situation sur les pesticides
notamment alors la France est conformée
aux droits européen sur les
néonicotinoïdes dans les interdisant à
nouveau ça suscité de la colère de la
part des notamment des producteurs de
betteraves à sucre qui compte sur ce sur
ce pesticide en fait sur ce produit
phytosanitaire aujourd'hui il y a une
plus qu'une colère il y a un sentiment
de ne pas être bien traité sur cette
question par les agriculteurs il y a je
crois un sentiment d'incompréhension qui
se traduit parfois en colère parce
qu'avec le sentiment qu'on ne doute pas
les agriculteurs des mêmes outils et
moyens que leurs collègues qui
espagnolent qui allemand qui belge et
donc c'est une réalité et sur un certain
nombre de sujets donc c'est une station
française est plus stricte on a eu une
tendance et c'est pas que sur
l'agriculture malheureusement en France
a sur transposé à se croire plus malin
que les autres et à dire on fait on fait
sans regarder qu'au fond on est dans le
même marché tout ça marcherait si on est
dans le même marché de souplesse et donc
il faut à chaque fois qu'on produit de
la norme qu'on se dise le bon niveau
pour la produire parce qu'après tout le
sujet s'il est environnemental ou
essayer de santé publique c'est aussi
important chez nos voisins européens que
chez nous et donc on a besoin de porter
ces sujets là au niveau européen et
deuxièmement l'interdiction ça produit
pas de la solution donc tandis qu'on
voit que sur des molécules il y a une
tendance générale qui est une tendance à
la réduction on aura toujours besoin en
tout cas assez longtemps d'un certain
nombre de molécules mais partout on peut
trouver des alternatives
il faut les chercher et donc c'est le
sujet c'est la recherche et l'innovation
qui permettra tandis qu'on a des
molécules qu'on utilise moins d'avoir
des solutions parce que l'interdiction
sur la solution à la fin c'est la perte
de souveraineté dernière question avant
d'être mise l'agriculture vous étiez
chargé des relations avec le Parlement
qu'elle regarde à ce titre vous portez
sur ce qui s'est passé à l'Assemblée
nationale un fiasco quand même pour
cette loi pour l'instant qui n'a pas pu
être voté est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est pas un fiasco pour la loi c'est un
fiasco pour le débat démocratique et en
même temps c'est quand même ici dans ce
lieu là qu'on a en images que doit se
passer la démocratie si jamais nous
n'arrivions pas à recrédibiliser donc
personne n'a intérêt à des crédibiliser
le Parlement parce que si c'est pas le
Parlement ou auront lieu les débats et
donc c'est un c'est un fiasco de ma
démocratique on est dans une phase où il
y a un certain nombre de gens qui se
font élire et en même temps quand ils
ont des attitudes comme celle qu'on a vu
viennent remettre en cause la démocratie
représentative et donc c'est leur
responsabilité quand on a été élu quand
on croit à la démocratie et en
particulier à la démocratie
représentative de faire en sorte que les
débats se passent dans des conditions de
confrontation d'idées mais pas
d'empêchement la confrontation que vous
avez ressenti merci beaucoup Marc feno
ministre de